let's go somewhere i can't fly
hi i'm christine mel christine served in
the united states air force for 20 years
she was the first woman to fly the f-35
christine's now an f-35 flight
instructor at lockheed martin
today i'll be breaking down clips from
movies and tv
about fighter pilots flares behind enemy
lines
we're being painted means that there is
a sam site on the ground that is
seeing you on their radar sam is a
surface-to-air missile
single missile tracking on it what
they're depicting here is kind of a mix
between a radar guided missile and an
infrared guided missile
we need a bigger heap in the fighter
community we don't say heat decoys we
say flares
[Music]
infrared guided missiles are typically
short-range missiles and they cannot fly
out this long a missile will typically
burn in this booster phase
and once that booster phase is burnt out
then that's it if you have a rapidly
reacting target that missile won't be
able to continue to turn left turn right
turn left go up
go down there's just no possible way
that this missile could continue to fly
the way that it does
what is it most aircraft have a master
caution light and that's just letting
you know there's something wrong with
your aircraft
i don't know of any aircraft that would
give you a master caution light
if you're being spiked by an enemy radar
so that doesn't make sense for this
scene at all
this airplane climbs straight up which
is the opposite thing
for what you want to do oh absolutely if
you've got
an infrared guided missile tracking on
you the number one thing you need to do
is to maneuver your aircraft and put out
flares they hardly put out any flares at
all
now climbing up high is giving this
infrared guided missile a nice blue
uncluttered background
for it to be able to track on you since
the heat-seeking missile what they
should have done is stay down low
and continue to fly within these canyons
because they're hiding closer to the
ground so there's
a lot of infrared clutter
[Music]
so the missile never locks on them to
begin with and is never launched aren't
you going to miss all this excitement
out running an f-22 iron man
tony stark in his iron man suit outruns
these up to 22s
initially at least by his acceleration
to supersonic
the f-22 is one of the fastest fighters
that we have out there
supersonic is just going faster than the
speed of sound
back in the day when we first broke the
sound barrier it was a bit of a violent
event today you'll end up going super
sonic multiple times during your flight
and not even notice it no way that's a
uav
what is it i can't see anything whatever
it was it just bought the farm
i think bogey has been handled sir
typically for your uh engaging another
aircraft
in order to say that it has been handled
you would want to verify that it has
splashed i.e is exploded and that it is
no longer flying
they're talking about a superhero in a
suit i think
all things are acceptable in this case
funny how that works huh disobeying
orders red tails
11 o'clock it looks like they're moving
livestock to me you're
always gonna wear your mask your mask is
not only giving you oxygen to be able to
breathe but also your microphone
is located in your mask so if you have
your mask drop and you're just talking
no one can hear you because there's too
much ambient noise in the cockpit
that no one can hear you over the radio
and it happens in almost every fighter
pilot movie
where they're dropping their mouse to
talk to each other to say something but
it's not realistic at all
let's go get it
where's lightning how are you lightning
taking a train from the front like you
should have done
it's my decision lightning stay in
formation in most cases
following your flight lead is the right
answer because they are typically more
experienced than you
and better than you in the airplane
in this situation the flight lead made a
very poor tactical decision his wingman
decided not to follow
his direction easy easy we gotta take
your head off he ended up killing the
train so he's gonna be praised but
likely he will be debriefed for
not following instructions just trying
to keep you boys inspired
glare dunkirk i don't hear what's
sitting ducks
in our helmets there's a visor that you
put down in front of your eyes
that's tinted which will help combat
glare
i'm on the bumper
of course that doesn't get rid of the
glare that shines off of the canopy or
different
things in the cockpit that makes it
difficult to see
you guys know if it's bright out you
wear your sunglasses and you're able to
see a little bit better
they are trying to cross the channel
looking for enemy fighters
if i was enemy fighter i would
definitely be flying high and try to
keep the sun behind me
so that i prevent anybody from seeing me
yeah he's down for the count
you can also do this in the middle of a
fight you can pull up into the sun which
will hopefully cause
a momentary blindness and give you
advantage albeit momentarily because
you can't stay in front of the sun
forever plain chicken pearl harbor
[Music]
okay we're going left right right right
right like we're going right or right
like we're going left well now you got
me all mixed up i don't know make up
your mind
the biggest training rule they're
violating is the bubble which is how
close you're allowed to get to another
airplane
in the air force in training at least
the closest
you can be to another airplane while
fighting them is a thousand feet
once you're done with training that will
typically be shrunk down to 500 feet
those are some smooth aces
you could definitely get kicked out for
a stunt like this not only they're
putting themselves in danger but they're
also risking
a total loss of two very expensive p40
aircraft stuff like this doesn't fly
most farm boys are grounded
pilot language the incredibles indian
golf 909 are transmitting in the blind
guard disengage there is a frequency
called
guard frequency that aircraft can use
to transmit emergencies transmitting in
the blind guard
transmitting in the blind on guard was a
very accurate statement for her to make
indian golf nine or niner so that is
recall sign in civil aviation
your call sign is your tail number so
november indicates that it's a civil
aircraft in the military we typically
fly around with call
signs that are assigned to each squadron
so you would hear
kong for example kong one one and those
are associated with military aircraft
mayday mayday indian gulf nine or niner
is buddies fight
aboard there are children when you say
buddy spikes you are getting radar
warning
indications from a friendly aircraft you
would say buddy spiked
to let them know that they have locked
you up for a couple reasons
the most common being hey man don't
shoot me because i'm a good guy too
there's a few things with her airplane
that makes it a bit unusual she does
have some sort of a radar warning
receiver
and or an ir warning receiver letting
her know that somebody has
shot at her
she's able to maneuver this airplane
like no commercial
jet that i've ever seen it's engaged
she does have afterburners on these
engines
and it gives you quite a bit of extra
thrust which is not something you would
see
in a civilian jet she's doing a
fantastic job at
being very descriptive with what she's
doing with her aircraft and where she is
i gotta give her mad props for that play
no more teamwork top gun
[Music]
[Applause]
we got a thousand not closure man it's
coming right at us
okay buddy what's on your mind i love
the movie top gun
it came out i think i was in fourth
grade fifth grade maybe
it inspired me to want to become a
fighter pilot albeit in the air force
and not the navy
but it is just a classic
airspeed 300 go get a map i'm going for
missile lock
the term missile lock may be a bit of a
misnomer in this case
great typically a fighter pilot will
lock up an enemy aircraft with their
radar that aircraft would have a radar
warning receiver that would let them
know
that they are being locked up that's
step one come on lock up baby
[Music]
bingo they already probably had
a radar lock in real life if this were
real life
okay buddy so not much would change the
bandit aircraft would feel
a little bit more threatened and
hopefully leave which he does bug out
your tail is clear big ones but yeah
we employ as two ships and four ships in
order to provide mutual support and the
core
element is a two ship you provide mutual
support to each other so that if you do
intercept a bandit that both of you are
together
controlling the bandit checking your six
for any other bandits
and ensuring you get the mission done
very common
[Music]
greetings no
that is not typical to rolling vernon
above an f5
and communicate via giving them the bird
but it does make for a funny story
and a great movie poster maneuvering
return to base
so typically we fly low levels around
500 feet
and roughly about 500 knots you can
certainly fly lower than that
but if you're talking 500 knots at 200
feet
your margin for error is very very small
in fact your time to die is so low that
any one little mistake
and you're going to impact the ground
time to die is a concept where
if you are flying level flight at low
altitude
your time to die is the time it takes
for you to impact the ground
if you're in a slight descent and you're
50 feet off the ground going super sonic
your time to die is about a half a
second
but to fly underneath the bridge
to try to gun somebody low altitude
to be going almost supersonic at 50 feet
off the ground that is very unrealistic
the part where they show a strike eel
getting gun they don't like that they
used to fly strike eagles and so that
made me a little sad
the turn radius of a fighter aircraft
we'll call it as about a half a mile
they're low altitude so their turn race
will be a little bit smaller because the
air is thicker
however these guys are turning around
skyscrapers very tightly
in between other skyscrapers
which would to me indicate a turn radius
of i would call it 500 feet or less
which is not something that's accurate
at all
so kind of silly but very exciting
signals
sky fighters
in this clip two french mirages are
chasing
a pilot who stole a mirage there are
international
signals that you can use when you're
intercepting another aircraft
the intercepting fighter should pull up
to the left wing
of the intercepted fighter and rock
their wings to let that intercepted
fighter know that he is being
intercepted
and then what you would do is fly
slightly in front of
and turn your nose across that aircraft
to lead them to where you want them to
go obviously the black mirage in this
case was
non-cooperative when the president
travels
we are airborne in a combat air patrol
looking for anybody who might be up to
no good so we
train in how to intercept usually
very slow-moving aircraft that don't
know where they are
the control zone is an area behind your
airplane you can kind of think of it
like a banner that you're towing behind
you at all times
closest to your airplane is defined as a
reaction limit so you don't want to be
too
close to a fighter that you cannot react
in time
to maintain the offensive or to avoid
hitting that airplane
the two mirages that intercept the black
mirage
those guys are flying awfully close to
this other mirage that they have no idea
what this person's intentions are so i
would not have flown as close as they
were depicting there
dogfight skycrawlers
you see this maneuver a lot hit the
brakes he'll fly right by
in flight school we learned the term go
up blow up
because it's not that effective
[Music]
so if you've got the air speed to go
vertical and you are a defensive fighter
then you certainly could but when you do
so
you are opening up your turn circle
because god's g is pulling you down
and you're going straight up so you're
very predictable and you open up your
turn circle so it's potentially
a lot easier for the offender to just
continue to pull a little bit harder
and gun you in the process until you end
up dying so i would say
it is not very common in real life for
an anime film they
accurately depicted the dynamic
environment of finding another airplane
but i don't necessarily think that the
moves that they use were the most
accurate
coffin corner green lantern
[Applause]
god damn it tom what the hell you need
those things
f35s what else the times that i have
shot missiles
in training i shot them against drones
given the nature of warfare and where
we're headed
i think that it's pretty accurate that
we'll be
fighting against drones a whole lot more
let's go somewhere i can't fly
what the hell is he up to
[Music]
they are referencing what i imagine the
ceiling of the aircraft
um where the drones can no longer
operate because
of whatever limitation that they have
the coffin corner as they reference it
in this movie
i have absolutely no idea we do use
the term aircraft sealing and the
ceiling of an aircraft
which is also the maximum altitude that
it can be flown at
could be driven by physiological
restrictions or it could be driven by
engine restrictions
eyeball rules of engagement set ceiling
at 50 000
feet roe or rules of engagement are
simply just the rules that you have to
abide by
as you're out there fighting
stall now his engine it said compressor
stall
which by the way is not what the f-35
will tell you
but that's okay so the engine said
compressor stall and yet it still
continued to burn
it sort of looked like it coughed a
little bit
but then as he went downhill it clearly
recovered itself
field calculation dunkirk
jack jewel two
70 gallons
68 gallons for the sweeter they are
referencing gallons in this clip
which is how all of these fighters
measured their fuel
back in the day modern fighters today
don't measure their fuel in gallons
they measure them in thousands of pounds
and you have to check your fuel
regularly
quarter what's your fuel you want to
make sure it's speeding accurately
did you turn back no no
i'm fairly confident it's just the case
that there's no trapped gas
and make sure that you're checking it so
that you don't overfly your bingo fuel
bingo fuel means you have to stop what
you're doing and hope now or else you
won't have enough gas to make it
understood conclusion i enjoyed watching
all the clips
they were very entertaining and humorous
in how inaccurate they are
in a lot of ways but as far as talking
about fighter pilot
stuff i could do that all day long if
you're interested in becoming a fighter
pilot i would
absolutely encourage you to do that it
is an
outstanding career very rewarding very
challenging very fun